all right looks like we're now
completely live for
the uh august ama so
i let my hair down a little bit today
you can see how long
it is and i've got a lot of questions
lined up
so i'll say a few things at the start
um you don't need to ask a question more
than once if it's in there it's in the
the thing
and i'll try to get to as many of them
as possible in the time that we have
lined up which is approximately
90 minutes so
let's start off with john
holloway's
question
can you recommend any specific stoic
writings on regret or on guilt
um
no nothing nothing in particular comes
to mind although i would suspect that
maybe there's there's some letter by
seneca that actually touches on the
topics um
it's weird because i've been getting
asked
similar questions and it may be by the
same person or by other people
recently it seems to be a topic of
some interest and concern
i mean the first thing to do is
you know you can realize that there's
nothing you can do to change the past
all you can do is focus on what you
choose to do in the present and you know
you think about if there's things that
you feel regret or guilt about
obviously you're making a judgment that
you're then applying to yourself and you
could think um
well is this judgment correct have i
just sort of inherited
assumptions from other people that might
be questionable but let's say there is
something to feel
objectively
guilty about or regret you did something
that you're like oh man that was bad
well then um
you look at why you did it look at your
reasoning process so you can change your
habits and assumptions and decisions for
the future because that's what you
actually have control over but there's
no particular
like stoic treaties on that or chapter
or letter that i can think of that comes
to mind although maybe i'm leaving
something out but
um
little yell says what are some good
pieces or arguments for the veneration
of the saints catholic thought is
rigorous and quite interesting but i've
never understood that particular aspect
so catholic thought is not something
that exists um
you can't generalize adequately
about a religious tradition and
community
that has been going on for you know 2000
years and includes
just thousands of like
different writers that are sort of at
the top tier and then many many more
so i i would i would always you know
avoid generalizing about catholic
thought because
you know just take some of the key
thinkers from the middle ages you know
uh anselm is not abelard is not aquinas
is not augustine is not and we could go
down the list and those are just a few
of them right
um the the idea about the veneration of
the saints
is that the saints provide
exemplars and are part of a community i
mean i if you wanted to read a book
i would suggest looking at saint
anselm's prayers and meditations
translated by benedict award i think
there's a new translation that's coming
out soon
anselm writes a lot of his prayers which
are intended to be used by not only
himself but others they circulated
around as a very
popular collection
um he revolutionizes prayer
and revolutionizes you could say the the
approaches to the saints in a very
sophisticated
and
well-thought-out way um the saints are
understood as being
you know people who started out as
sinners and screw-ups like the rest of
us and somehow you know
progressed in some way and i mean
veneration
that's that's kind of a side note really
um the key things are to like
think about what it is that you you want
to get out of contemplating these these
people i would say and then
think about you know whether there is
something like a communion meaning a
capacity for relationship and
ongoing dialogue or something along
those lines
joseph says who do you think has the
more correct view on space and time
kant or aristotle especially interested
in your take on the transcendental
aesthetic as i'm reading it right now
i mean i'm not a conscience um i
don't buy the idea that space and time
are merely
forms of you know
our perception of the world and we kind
of just impose them on the booming
buzzing
craziness
uh that is
whatever reality is i'm i'm more of a
realist that way than a conscient
idealist
does aristotle corner the market on
space and time i mean it's not even
clear sometimes other than you know
really cool lapidary formulas like time
is the number of motion but then you
gotta go like well what the hell does
that mean right
and and spell that out um i mean i guess
you could say i would lean more towards
aristotle but there's other thinkers who
come after him
who likewise um speculate about the
nature of time think about augustine in
confessions you know towards the end of
the book the metaphysical uh chapters or
books of of the work and there's lots of
other thinkers who
consider it as well so
um it's sort of like asking me
which do you like better
on pizza
mushrooms
or
just pineapple and i'd be like well
not really a fan of either you know by
themselves um so that that might be a
i don't know if that's a decent answer
um
mark says uh wanted to share we had our
first meeting for a new local
existentialism
reading group yesterday it was great fun
thank you for continuing to inspire us
to put philosophy into practice well
that's that's really cool so mark is in
south africa he's a friend and colleague
of mine
and a local existentialism reading group
that sounds pretty cool i don't think
that we have
something like that here in the
milwaukee area
although i could be mistaken maybe i
need to look on meetups and see whether
we have something
like that so i i applaud you for putting
something like that together we're
having uh at least i'm having trouble
you know um
coordinating our local stoic fellowship
in part because it's difficult to find a
good place to
to meet um postcovid
but
yeah that's really cool
all right galen um how should i read the
euthademus it seems ridiculous and i
suppose it's meant to be is it is it a
critique of sophists a message that
philosophy is important and just ignore
the idiots both or or other
it's a critique of the sophists
you know i mean plato writes a lot of
dialogues
if you don't enjoy the euthademus
i don't think you need to read it or
re-read it
given that there's so many other
dialogues that are considered you know
historically
uh more central to the platonic
tradition than the euthodemus it's sort
of like saying you know what's supposed
to be going on here in this storage
closet you know and and we've got the
whole house to go through
um it is a critique of the sofas and
it's a critique in action where socrates
does some takedowns and
so you know what you know
how should you read it there's lots of
ways to read a platonic dialogue you can
like say i just want the arguments the
way that analytic philosophers do
you can say that the dramatic context
matters and you don't have to be a
straussian thank god to do that because
people have been attending to that you
know forever
you can look at the key ideas that are
being developed and whether you can go
further with them
you can think about the nature of
philosophy versus sophistry there's lots
and lots of ways to
take any platonic dialogue and go
somewhere with it there doesn't have to
be
just one thing and you know like you say
it seems ridiculous and i suppose it's
meant to be
so
parts of it are ridiculous in the sense
that
you know they're meant to raise a laugh
right ridicule has to do with rhesus
with laughter and
yeah we're supposed to laugh at these
these uh sophists who are claiming to
know everything claiming to do it
everything i mean this is a bit of a
side note but these two jackass brothers
um they are like the sophist sophists
right so think about the other so-called
sofas that we we run across you know
gorgeous doesn't claim to do anything
other than each rhetoric right he's
pretty circumspect in his claims
thrasymachus can teach you about justice
does he know about everything else no
but these guys can like talk about
anything and everything and so you know
um they're kind of ripe for for
takedowns i would say
uh a lot of questions just skipped a
little bit so jeremy our mental thoughts
on philosophy of math i don't really
have a lot of thoughts on philosophy of
math
um it's a cool area i'm not a specialist
in it
um
so that's pretty much it thoughts on
anarcho-syndicalism and socialism well
you know two different
things
and um it depends on what we mean by
socialism you know here in america
unfortunately we have a tradition of uh
conservatives in the past and fake
conservatives in the present because
people who call themselves conservatives
today are not not conservative at all
um they've left behind you know most of
what counted as conservativism they they
use the word socialist to describe
anything that they don't like that you
know might have
government involved or you know stuff
like that but you know uh socialism
can be done in many different ways i
think that uh there are some things
where the state ought to be in control
of it we shouldn't privatize it we
shouldn't try to you know look for free
market solutions because they always end
up being crony
uh capitalism and corruption and you
know monopolies and stuff like that
which is not not you know proper
capitalism
um
you know and and i think that we should
like
think about uh the impact of things on
the entire community and we should you
know try to have policies that are much
more oriented towards the
ordinary person than than rich elites
and i think we should tax the [ __ ] out
of elites at this point too and i don't
buy the oh they're going to go elsewhere
they already go elsewhere they already
find ways to evade it
one way you could look at socialism
would be people pay their fair share for
the benefits that they're receiving just
by being within a
society so i'm you know i'm cool with
that
um
all right yoda what do you think about
the u.s china-taiwan issue i think that
china should
decide you know that taiwan is always
going to be off limits i think taiwan
should be
recognized at this point as an
independent country with its own economy
with its own
mix of cultures with its own history and
i think that
you know
there's kind of a good consensus among
all of china's neighbors
that
china's
overstepping i mean it's bad enough what
they've done to type that um it's bad
enough what they're doing to
minorities not just in xinjiang but you
know historically throughout the the
place and uh
it's bad enough what went on in hong
kong right i don't i don't want to see
that sort of crap happening with taiwan
and
yeah it's probably
enough to say about it um
erickson brown how great and important
of a philosopher philosophers
wittgenstein in your opinion
i think that wittgenstein uh
is worth reading but i think that his
importance was greatly
oversold as a result of the kind of
self-impoverishment of philosophy
that
is characteristic of early
analytic philosophy
with some exceptions john wisdom
you know
anscombe
foot people like that show that you can
well mcintyre too show that you can do
work in an analytic context
and um
engage with people outside of analytic
philosophy i think that victon stein had
he read and seriously
thought about
many more people in the history of
philosophy he wouldn't have spent so
much time
trying to reinvent wheels and doing
a
social job of doing that but his works
are interesting and
challenging and worth
checking out
so yeah
a lot of these what are your thoughts
what are your thoughts about the
philosophy of science i don't have any
thoughts about the philosophy of science
i don't work in the philosophy of
science these are these are far too
general what do you think of fuzzy logic
uh
i guess it's good for some things uh i
wouldn't adopt it as the you know
be all and end all of logic um
massachusetts says which christian
secular scholar do you agree with in
terms of
the distortion of the bible especially
the old testament i don't know i mean
i'm not i'm not spending a lot of time
reading uh
up to date
stu you know uh criticism uh you know
whether it's form or
uh
you don't even remember all the
different uh
things that it fits into
so i don't have a particular scholar who
i agree with in terms of a distortion of
the bible which is you know
ask me about a particular
book and something like that maybe i can
give you an answer
uh
oldies any book or other resources
recommendations to start learning logic
depends on what kind of logic you want
to learn
[Music]
there's a lot of things that get called
logic and there is no absolute consensus
among philosophers about exactly what
logic is or how far it extends
um there's overlaps with what we call
critical thinking
with
communication studies with rhetoric with
dialectic with
other fields as well so i would say like
if your goal is to study formal logic
there's textbooks out there
and i haven't done a survey of that for
a long time because i haven't taught a
lot of classes for quite a while but
standby or the sort of standard when i
was an undergraduate and a graduate
student was copy
and copy's introduction to logic has
gone through many many editions it's a
good book
um hurley is a big favorite of many
others as well but yeah i mean most
logic textbooks are going to cover
more or less the same kind of stuff
with a few variations right so find
yourself a decent logic textbook and
just kind of you know plow away with
that
and then you know if you're interested
in the connect in the connections of
logic with other stuff again kopi
um wrote quite a bit about that i
remember you know going through pretty
much everything i could find by the guy
when i was an undergraduate
um
if you're
interested in
going beyond just formal logic and
aristotelian logic then grand priest is
somebody who you should check out he's
got a
introduction to i think it's
non-standard logics which talks about a
lot of cool stuff
there's modal logic as well
um
which priests will cover but other
people will have like entire textbooks
on
and then you know if you're thinking
about like logic and argumentation
you might check out people like umberto
echo you know or
kaim perlman
who are
attentive to where logic intersects with
semiotics or intersects with rhetoric or
things like that so those those might be
a good place to
get started
um
emergency as a means says what do you
make of the assumption of a need
to create conditions of rigor like that
of the sciences in philosophy it seems
to me like a relatively common but
deeply limited persuasion okay so this
is a great question
to begin with
if you look at the history of the
sciences
you realize that
or if you know scientists who currently
work or you think about how science gets
presented you realize that rigor is
something that is occasionally attained
sometimes is kind of a straight jacket
preventing people from
you know progressing in the sciences and
considering
interesting explanations for things
cool experiments to carry out
vigor is kind of a buzzword and
sometimes it means something and
sometimes it doesn't in the hands of
philosophers who are enamored of the
sciences
much of the time you can be guaranteed
that they don't really know enough of
the sciences to make that comparison and
that what's going on here is more of a
more of a wish fulfillment ideology than
anything else a way of like saying what
we do is rigorous what you do isn't you
know
um
so
i i i'm pretty skeptical of those sorts
of
claims we also have to deal with the
fact that science
isn't a single thing it doesn't boil
down to the quote scientific method
which doesn't actually cover
the methods that scientists have used to
use
um doesn't all precede the way that you
know in this cookie cutter way that we
teach people
in textbooks and uh as undergraduates or
in high school or stuff like that so i
i'm pretty skeptical of that sort of
thing
um
your average french canadian immigration
recently discovered my cousin as an
insult debating him was useless
can you recommend philosophy
psychoanalysis both talked about the
metaphysics of bigotry
um
essence of a woman his acts and facts
either explicitly endorsed or
temporarily i i don't know what all of
this is asking
frankly the metaphysics of bigotry i'm
not even sure what that would mean
um
i mean you mentioned fonon he's he's
worth reading there's lots of stuff out
there
that talks about
maybe maybe what you mean by the
metaphysics of bigotry is like the
thought processes
behind it i think there's lots and lots
of stuff out there that you could look
at going all the way back to you know i
mean think about like nietzsche right um
nietzsche identified the anti-semites of
his time for the morons that they were
but also the pan-germanists as well
but you know going forward there's all
sorts of ways to
[Music]
identify
what's happening and not just in
philosophy but like sociology and in
literature
you know
in the fine arts
so i don't have any particular
recommendations of that but
yeah i mean going back to your original
point discovered my cousin as an incel
so
and debating him that means that you're
trying to
like convince him otherwise
and um i'm guessing that he's espousing
all sorts of stuff that he's like read
on websites or
in shitty books about like you know the
nature of women and the nature of men
and buying into you know like women you
know dating apps have destroyed
everything because hypogammy and blah
blah blah blah blah right
you're probably not going to make much
progress
with a person like that and debating
them
certainly isn't going to be the way to
go
people's minds are very
very infrequently changed by
debates i would say
so
maybe it's like offering
better examples and
putting up with his silly [ __ ] um
but also like laying limits down on it
like when he says
for example i got a i got a
biological dad who i love very much but
who watches fox news and whenever he
brings up you know the latest thing from
fox news i'll just say well you know i
don't think that's true and then you
know the conversation pauses for for a
bit
and then we move on to better topics so
you know when he starts talking about
like why he can't get a girlfriend
because of blah blah blah blah blah that
some you know huckster has uh put out
there to to you know
draw an audience and make money
um
you said well that's not true and uh i
don't see any point in debating this
with you
uh love you as a cousin but this is
gonna be an unproductive conversation so
you know if this is all we're gonna talk
about i guess i'll see you if we got
other stuff to talk about let's let's
talk about that you know if you do those
sorts of things then
um you leave the door open to eventually
them
moving on to something better
um
adn hope uh i'm curious what are your
thoughts on moral platonism what are its
shortcomings is attentible as positing
god a superior moral theory i have no
idea what you're talking about is moral
platonism that is not a term that i've
seen uh out there i expect that must be
something from somebody's rather
eccentric
classification of moral systems or
something like that
um
positing god is not a is not a moral
theory that you know god would be just a
component of a moral theory not a whole
moral theory in itself
um and i'm curious why you think that
satanists don't believe in god when
clearly they do because plato talks
about the gods
many many times in his works you know
and the form of the good
winds up in christian and jewish
neoplatonism being
god so i'm not i'm not sure where that
that's coming from uh dominic i want to
thank you for your work i applied for
the phd again after three years and was
accepted nice congratulations because of
your lectures my fire for philosophy has
never
been extinguished so that's that's
awesome to
read um
you know ideally the lectures
um are just a supplement for the works
that they're referencing
and explaining so
you know hopefully you've been reading a
lot of uh great philosophical works in
those those three years as well
um you're definitely gonna need it going
into the phd right
all right uh
andre since you're an eclectic i assume
you don't buy stoicism wholesale what
are the things you leave outside and why
yeah i mean it's pretty rare to find
somebody who actually does buy stoicism
wholesale
because the classic stoics didn't all do
that you know think about seneca where
he will say
for example you know the orthodox stoic
position is that the virtues are living
things within us and
clearly that doesn't make any sense and
here's some arguments why
so you know orthodoxy and stoicism is as
tricky as orthodoxy in any other
community
as well
um
i mean i think you could say that i
differ
first of all
on a number of points where the people
who call themselves in the present
traditional stoics are real
sticklers
i don't buy the pantheism you know um i
don't even if we like change it to
pan-enthusiasm and have as as we would
get from
cicero's um on the nature of the gods
kind of a hierarchy of beings that looks
a little bit more uh platonic or
neoplatonic or aristotelian where you've
got these you know lowercase g gods that
look a lot like angels helping out
running the universe um i i don't think
that this is a really tenable schema
um
you know i i think that the
stoics are
maybe
a bit too
um
[Music]
what would we call it a bit too
uncompromising about some of the
emotions particularly anger
i lean more towards
the position that you see aristotelians
and platonous and epicureans
and a lot of
you know early christian writers having
about anger which is you really got to
watch it and it's problematic a lot of
the time but the stoics are wrong to
condemn it entirely the position by the
way of rational emotive behavior therapy
as well
[Music]
you know i think that the stoic
discussions of the virtues are great
i think that the
idea that you're either
vicious or virtuous and there's nothing
in between and that
although virtues might you know augment
in a certain way you can't actually like
grow
in them so like one instance of justice
is just as good as another instance of
justice i don't buy any of that i'm
actually
i'm going to be doing a presentation on
that in the
midwest seminar in ancient and medieval
philosophy later this
fall
here over at marquette university
so if you're here locally you can hear
me talk about that
um
i mean what else do i do i
differ with them on
um
i don't know that i that i buy the
anthropology that they have with the
like single ruling part and then the
senses and stuff like that
kind of more attracted to a faculty
psychology like you see in
platonism and aristotelianism
so i mean that's probably more or less
it
there's probably more stuff but i'd have
to think about that
all right um
salmon salvador is a catholic how do you
reconcile us having a soul with its
attribute independent of our body and
the fact that our brains determines the
latter so much i sort of like bexonian
dualism thoughts i don't even know what
berksonian dualism is supposed to mean
because
um i i don't necessarily get that out of
reading bergstone
um
i don't have to reconcile having a soul
uh in the body of the brain determining
the latter so much
because
those don't strike me as contradictory
um
brain can determine the body and
determine the soul i mean
um there's lots of different
explanations for
what could exceed the the brain
you know going
all the way back to i suppose aristotle
right
who uh was not a dualist in any sense
so
to me this isn't something i really
worry about much
um
bruno uh i'm reading leotard i'm finding
him unconvincing so far any thoughts on
him i never was really able to get into
leotard and i think it might be i just
couldn't appreciate
the stuff that he was doing
um i gotta go back and re-read the
post-modern condition
um
just to you know own up a little bit
but i've always find reading him kind of
a chore frankly
so
you know and he seems to me a little bit
like and this is this is a common thing
for for
um
french philosophy of his generation he's
he's really willing to you know in a
critical way take on all these other
thinkers and then use their stuff and
sometimes it's revealing and a lot of
times you're like well why did you go
down that route instead of this route
you know
so
um
1117 says are there any modern
phenomenological philosophers you like
yeah lots of them depends on what you
mean by modern
right
um so
there's lots of people in the
phenomenological movement as it gets
started i mean
whosoever's important i find reading
horseroll really boring and dry except
for a few pieces
he does actually have a really good
encyclopedia entry on phenomenology
though but there's a lot of people of
his his generation that are also you
know really great to read like mock
shaler
um you know his his student edith stein
um who by the way was the invited guest
for the first day of um ole miss studies
a sort of transnational
meeting that took place i want to say
1932
she was the guest of honor and she was
um you know engaging with with them on
that
there were quite a few thomas who were
attracted to phenomenology
foiling is a good example of of one amy
for it
and that's in part because
what phenomenology was doing is very
similar to what bergson was doing and
what maurice blondel before bergstone
was doing with the method of of
imminence and bergson and blondel along
with gabriel marcel also a
phenomenologist
effectively revitalized metaphysics in
france um in the early
20th and late 19th century
um
obviously heidegger is very important um
you know jean-paul sartre is a
phenomenologist ortega e gossett is not
a phenomenologist as such i would say
but certainly
learned from them quite a bit
and we can keep going on and on and on
and on right there's still people out
there doing phenomenology today
including many of my uh friends and
colleagues
um
one just down the road at marquette
sebastian lift is heavily involved in
the phenomenological community so
there's yeah there's a lot of
phenomenologists um that
i like um including some of my
colleagues
all right um
miroslav any thoughts on the works of
hans georg gottamer worth reading uh
interesting guy uh in the
phenomenological tradition so to speak
doing the hermeneutic stuff
a student of heidegger and has got some
good works on you know platonic dialogue
good discussions of hegel
obviously his book truth and method
worth reading as well
matthew says i wanted to ask about your
perspective on the natural humanist
philosophers
from the renaissance particularly
neoplatonic esoteric
natural philosophy such as agrippa or
pico
not a specialist in that stuff i don't
really have a perspective on that so
um
there are people out there who do that
as a matter of fact i did have a
colleague at one time at marist who was
a specialist in renaissance philosophy
but you're not going to find a lot of
people doing that sort of thing
uh aosa do you have any tips for reading
philosophy faster i started reading
philosophy recently and it took me an
hour and 30 minutes to read two pages i
plan to stick with it i do
and my advice is don't read philosophy
faster
read it at the pace that it requires
it's sort of like saying
do you have any advice for
cleaning my my house faster
you know and you walk into it and
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done i mean yeah you can go faster and
do a shoddy job that is going to
require you to like fix it later anyway
or you can
do it right the first second third time
and uh that's the better way to go if if
you find that a passage takes a while
that's just fine it takes us all a while
you know um
just you know as an example so like i've
got here's two books at two different
uh extremes
here's a jg ballard i'm going to be
doing a
worlds of speculative fiction next um
saturday specifically on
this book and two other ones crash and
uh high rise
and
you know this is uh
not only is this a novel so you can read
it fairly quickly anyway but ballard is
a
a re a writer who makes reading kind of
effortless
so
i mean you could read this in less than
the space of an afternoon right
here's another book that's a little bit
of a
contrast on the other end
i mean sometimes
reading through a paragraph could take
an hour to figure out what the hell this
guy is actually saying you know and
that's okay
um
some some other stuff that would be like
maybe in between a great author like
julia annis
um you know this is a difficult dance
book it is
not including all the bibliography
like that 451 pages
uh
with lots and lots of notes but really
well worth reading i highly recommend
julia hannas
a great person too i've met her and
interacted with her
it takes what it takes you know don't
don't try to speed things up people who
advise you to like cut corners
they're giving you bad advice so
right ridicule would you support
democratizing the workplace
slash a shift towards more worker
cooperatives and representation
yeah um i i think that that would be a
great thing i think that we also
you know democratizing isn't uh enough
because
you know we also need to think about the
legal framework that has changed so much
over
my lifetime making things you know much
more difficult for workers in many
respects and easier for
corporations and management uh in many
respects
um we need to think about the culture
that we're in where
a lot of people vote against their
economic interests because they've been
boondoggled by
a uh increasingly more and more cynical
republican party and uh you know
admittedly
uh dysfunctional democratic party uh not
providing a particularly good
alternative other than to say well you
don't want to slide into the fascism
that these people are
pushing
um so there's lots of stuff i i think
that um
when we think about
companies
and workplaces
the measure ought to be how are things
for the people at the bottom
you know how are they being treated how
are they being compensated how are they
how are they being protected
um it shouldn't be just about how much
revenue is being generated
or you know what do the people at the
top think the people at the top are
always happy with how [ __ ] is going
right unless they're not making as much
money or they're they're winding up you
know losing out on some power struggle
we should be thinking about what are
things like for the secretarial staff
what are things like for the janitors
what are things like for in restaurants
the dishwashers and busboys and
people you know at those ends i think
that's very important
all right uh
andre what are some helpful books
someone should read to define a solid
political position
i mean i don't know i don't think that
just reading uh
a particular curriculum is by itself can
help you develop whatever a solid
political position
is there's there's books out there that
provide
overviews of political philosophy
and they're usually at a fairly high
level of generality but they they can be
okay i guess
um i don't keep up on that kind of
contemporary literature i mean i would
say
you know reading and thinking about
without trying to take as like the
blueprint
for what politics ought to look like
classical
all the way up to like 20th and 21st
century
literature in political theory broadly
speaking could be useful
but does any one book stand out not not
for me so
um
let's see here
ethan says is there any advice you could
give for giving getting out of a rut of
not reading philosophy or learning
this is going to sound
kind of silly but
there's really no substitute for this
the way you get out of that rut is by
actually
doing some reading you know
you make time for it um you know i i do
actually have some like nuts and bolts
advice i use a google calendar for
scheduling
what i do during the day my work you
know my video production
reading exercise
time with my my wife
events that we're going to client
appointments
and i will um
so i found out with exercise i had to
create appointments for myself as if i
was meeting with a client
and
that allowed me to stick to it otherwise
i was letting it slide
so
i would do something like that for
yourself for reading
and you don't have to like you know read
the
phenomenology of spirit don't pick
something that's like super hard
pick something
that is uh more
workable um
let's see what i got over here
so
like you know
here's uh
philip k dick's you know short stories
philosophical stuff going on in those
right
um this one's got actually got we can
remember it for you wholesale which is a
great story um
i would you know um start with stuff
like that or i mentioned this like
survey book where julia annis is telling
you all about ancient philosophy and
their views on the virtues and habits
and morality and life as a whole you
know if you just read some of this and
be gentle with yourself
you might have to read stuff over
several times before it makes sense or
sticks that's okay
sometimes you got to do that so
andre says thank you thank you andre
that's very very nice of you
um
impeach design oh he's got a thing about
reading pastor yeah zeitgeist how would
conservatives today not be conservative
though they believe in traditional
morality no they don't most of them
believe basically
in a few little bits and pieces of it
and they and they don't follow it i mean
traditional morality would say don't lie
don't cheat don't steal don't uh you
know rob people of what's what's due to
them and
i mean if you're if you're voting
republican you're voting for things that
directly contradicts all of that so
that's not conservative at all i mean
great examples are like the the whole
nra gun nutter uh second amendment thing
the nra
when i was a kid was for gun control and
it was about like hunters and
responsible gun owners it wasn't uh this
corrupt organization
shelling out lots of money to
to basically almost every republican and
some democrats to essentially buy their
way in and cover up the gun industry
that's not conservative
that's actually radical that's a radical
change
so
you know
conservatives people who call themselves
conservatives today they don't believe
in any sort of traditional morality
that's that's all just smoking lies
[ __ ] at this point i mean they might
have been able to claim that 20 years
ago
but
nobody should be fooled today
you know that's not to say that their
opposition is automatically you know for
traditional morality and
why why would it be good to be for
traditional morality in the first place
a lot of traditional morality is
you know bigotry and [ __ ] you got to
be very selective if you're like a
virtue ethicist or you're interested in
you know living a philosophical life
you've got to have left behind the
people that call themselves
conservatives today i mean they're so
many of them are just
um
reprobates and degenerates and um but
you know it's often been like that right
in in history so
all right uh
june
juneton uh says any thoughts on talk of
grounding in
metaphysics it seems metaphysics has
taken a very neo-aristotelian turn over
the last 10 years what do you think of
the contemporary state of metaphysics i
don't worry about the contemporary state
of metaphysics so i don't know what that
what that means or looks like
and i'm pretty surprised to hear about a
neo-aristotelian turn because
neo-aristotelians have been a minority
for a very long time
as far as i can tell
and
grounding in metaphysics
i don't really worry about that so much
um every time that i've seen somebody
claim to provide a grounding
for things it never really turns out to
be such
so i you know i i'm more interested in
like
things where it
the questions are kind of smaller like
what is human nature you know uh is
there such a thing what does it look
like does it develop how complicated is
it
you know
how do we distinguish
reality from appearances maybe
appearances have their own kind of
reality those sorts of things i don't
worry about like foundation or grounding
or things like that myself
all right um
stigmarus
says uh thanks for your lessons i'm a
recent high school graduate going into
college and i thank you so much for the
videos you made i love philosophy
hope to learn so much more well i mean
in a way you're in a great position
because
hopefully you know
fate willing you've got your whole life
ahead of you
and you've got
decades and decades to
read and discuss and study and apply and
experiment with the at least a portion
because all we can do now is like get a
little portion
of the philosophy that's out there and
how exciting for you that's that's
really wonderful i mean one of these
the few regrets i have and no it's not
really a great a regret or a complaint
it's just that yeah this you know it's
too bad right
is the fact that um
as somebody who's 51 years old going to
turn 52 in just a week
week or two
um
you know i got maybe another 30 years
and
i kind of wish i had more time
given that now i have a really solid
conception of what it is that i wanted
to
but i got to do it with this this body
that's uh slowly breaking down
and um
is you know it's got a lot of like
chronic pain and and uh
i can't remember things quite as well as
i i used to
um
so
yeah enjoy it while you can
um
[Music]
stigmarus
make make as much use of it as you can
all right serum um
completely out of topic this is an ama
you can ask about whatever you want
what is your favorite music album
that is almost impossible for me to say
i don't i don't even have a favorite
band anymore
i think if you'd asked teenager
something greg
it probably would have been iron
maiden's peace of mind because iron
maiden was my favorite band and peace of
mind is a really really great album
um
i actually nowadays if you ask me like
what's what's your favorite iron maiden
album i would say killers
um although i do like bruce dickinson
singing better than paul diano's
um
but you know
i don't even have like a
a favorite band and if you were to ask
me like what are your top five or top
ten there's bands that would get in
there but
it's
it changes from you know
one one week to the next
so
there's a lot of non-metal bands that i
really love too like you know new model
army for example
or
guess what i'm gonna get to see over my
birthday weekend
down in chicago
duran
duran um
so it i don't really have a good answer
to that sort of thing
um
joel says what's your opinion of marx's
1815 paris manuscripts in general do you
accept marx's critique of hegel or is it
not your area of interest i mean that's
a weird dichotomy do you accept it or is
it not an area of your interest you
could be it could be an area of your
interest and you could still not accept
it you know
as a matter of fact you can you can
research people who you and and work on
people and teach them who you totally
disagree with i
pretty routinely teach david hume and i
enjoy reading him but i disagree with
him fundamentally about many different
things
so um
i mean do i do i agree with marx's
critique of hegel yeah okay kind of not
i mean
um i think that marx
is a
pretty
all-over-the-map kind of writer
and that one of the challenges
of marxists and marxists come in all
different varieties is to figure out
what should we actually buy what should
we not
how do we put this stuff together how do
we apply it
it's complicated by the fact that marx
tried to kind of bogart
um uh
uh you know the the whole
radical progressive movement i mean you
can see this for example in the
communist manifesto where it's like
these kinds of socialism are all wrong
or they're not completely wrong but
here's where they go bad this is why
what we're putting forward is the the
best thing
um
so yeah um
it looks like joel asked that same
question twice mps design uh
is continuing a conversation
um
one two three for when do you what do
you think about helen keller conspiracy
theories
many zoomers think that either keller
handlers lied about her ability to know
things or communicate this is something
completely new to me i i had no idea
that there were helen keller conspiracy
theories i think that i'll say this
um if that's the sort of [ __ ] given the
world that we're living in and the many
different things that you could be like
devoting your time to
if that's the focus of somebody's
you know
decision to apply their intellect
that's probably kind of telling
about them
um i don't really care about helen
keller one way or the other
and um i find it bizarre that people
that this would become an object of
controversy but i suppose that anything
can become an object with controversy
right
so all right uh ben says uh i'm starting
a local philosophy club at my local
public library any advice on which
direction to take things
i think it'd be good to keep things
pretty open-ended at least in the
beginning yeah um
that's a good idea you know uh i i would
like what i would suggest doing
is
maybe having something that you use as a
focal point right so it's not like
totally open-ended
um you want to maybe give them a short
reading and the library can probably
help out with that like providing people
with photocopies because they do this in
great books clubs so you could say like
oh today we're going to look at um
you know the apology of socrates and
we're going to discuss these ideas in it
and then you know creating handouts for
people people love to have takeaways
so that can be quite useful
you know you might also look into
the society of philosophers in america
sophia
um
they
support and promote and provide
resources for
people doing
kind of general interest philosophy
clubs provided that they're oriented
towards
promoting dialogue um so that's that
that would be a good
thing to do
and you know you realize that
you're going to have kooks come in who
have some very
strongly held but poorly formed ideas
and they're going to want to communicate
them because they're lonely people um
and you know you don't have to like
refute them you can just say all right
well that that's fine we're talking
about this over here
not that as you see me do sometimes in
my my videos right that might be a
useful thing to start learning how to do
because you're gonna keep getting them
coming in
um
further wrote uh back to phenomenology
what do you think of phenomenology as a
study i think that phenomenology is such
a vast field with so many different ways
in which it's done and so many different
authors and so many different traditions
that there isn't a what do i think of it
um there's it depends on who you're
you're you're thinking about who you
know are we talking about his role i
mentioned his role is
worth reading i don't know that you have
to necessarily read everything that has
been published by the guy
let alone everything that he wrote
because reading everything that he wrote
means going to
um
uh
loyvan
and uh
learning you know
his shorthand and pouring through the
archives which uh has to be you know
some really
demanding and also dull work but you
know
reading historical reading the cartesian
meditations uh is is worth doing the
crisis manuscript is certainly worth
reading
um i you know i find heidegger and mock
schaeler and and
edith died and people like that much
more exciting to read gabriel marcel as
well
um
but you know different strokes for
different folks so
all right um
max says
i recently read up on some of leibniz's
ideas and found him interesting how do
you think one should approach his work
especially since his works are mostly
essays well
read them
realize that he is writing in a context
in which there's
important debates going on between
several different modern
philosophies or broadly speaking and
some you know stuff that's coming from
ancient and medieval
you know leibniz for example thinks that
it's foolish to throw away the idea of
substantial forms just because the
scholastics
seem to be a bit more abund uh when it
comes to that um
you know he's got some really
fascinating ideas and
you know a lot of what he does write his
essays there's also that like uh you
could call it
almost like a manifesto
the morditology
um
he also you know writes
long tree dc's
like his theodicy and he's he's got a
lot of um letters that he writes back
and forth as well that are
pretty interesting to look at too
um
so
yeah and keep in mind that leibniz
is um
[Music]
you know he's responding to and reacting
to a lot of other
thinkers
of the time so
um
let's see
one two three four who's your favorite
president what are some reasons why
i don't think i have a favorite
president
i don't i don't you know lionize them as
great men or stuff like that you know
what i want to see in a president is
um
doing the right sorts of things you know
steering us towards a a better union
than what we've currently got
so
yeah
i mean
i could pull a guy out of the air and
say abraham lincoln
but you know lincoln had his his flaws
as well
so i don't know that he's actually a
favorite because i don't know that i
have a favorite president
uh p petros this is a kind of funny one
do you have any procrastination tips i'm
taking it you don't mean tips on how to
procrastinate and that you've already
got that down
as well which i do too
um
yeah so
i i do have a
i'll give you a couple tips one is
so you started procrastinating and and
you have a tendency towards it realizing
that
and then choosing to
um you know do something
in the present about it is is quite
helpful um
you don't have to like you know
absolutely clear your schedule or your
to-do list or something like that of all
the things that you haven't gotten to in
order to make some progress
you don't want to use the
progress that you are making
as
a way of not thinking about the things
that you still have to do of course
right because that that's a typical
procrastination trick oh you know i
vacuumed the carpet so therefore the the
emails i need to get to it's okay if i
put them off that that's bad logic
um
but i would say
one of the things that does happen with
procrastination is
especially when you're thinking about
like
writing a paper
or writing an email to somebody
you don't do it on time
and then you're like oh man in order to
make it up i need to like really do a
good job on this
in the future
so
i better like you know find a good time
to do that and then i'll like write the
the perfect email or the perfect paper
or you know i'll clean this place up so
much it'll be like you know it's never
been lived in or something like that
that is going to screw you up so as soon
as you as soon as you find yourself
doing that
procrastination and perfectionism often
go hand in hand
um you want to like be attentive to that
and then say
i don't have to do a perfect job on this
i just need to get something done
for this right that's
you know a real achievement
even if it's not perfect is way better
than an ideal not real
perfect achievement so maybe that'll
help
us i don't really understand aristotle's
idea of the formal cause could you
explain formal cause is the uh structure
of the thing
you know um and it you could say it's
workings and and you know the material
is is you could here we use this sort of
visual metaphor the materials underneath
the formal cause is superimposed on it
now you have a substance that's that's
the way that aristotle talks about it
and it's going to vary from thing to
thing to thing right obviously
uh the soul being the form of the body
is not exactly the same thing
as the
structure of the water bottle being the
the form of the material that this water
bottle is composed of or the
you know overarching levels of structure
uh whether you know just
that of the sentence the word the
paragraph and the book um
you know the meaning of the book is is
one thing then we also have the actual
structure of it so there's a number of
different ways of having formal
causality maybe that'll help out
you know it probably
one of the ways i think people get
screwed up with aristotelian causality
is they're like a formal cause is only
one kind of thing a final cause is only
one kind of thing and everything has to
fit into that bucket
well it's a lot more complicated when we
look at what aristotle actually says and
then when we try to apply it
in
the world that we live in
uh serum what do you make of nietzsche's
the zarathustra
um i recently listened to the book i was
impressed by the way
in which it was written
than
actually believing in its ideas that's a
good distinction right you can you can
say nietzsche is a great stylist
um you don't necessarily have to buy
into the ideas to
appreciate the style
um
i mean you know nietzsche is not a
systematic writer um
thus far zarathustra has a lot of
discourses
and
you know you could like buy
one of them without buying all of them
or even
part of a discourse without buying the
totality of the single discourse that's
that's certainly possible
mark has has a bit of note here i'm busy
reading kant's third critique the
critique of judgment i read for about an
hour each night getting through about
two or three pages each day see there's
there's a great example of
somebody who's uh plowing through a
difficult work the third critique is in
parts you're like holy [ __ ] what the
hell's going on here right
um
and i mean other parts are a little bit
more straightforward but
some of it is is really
both mind-blowing and mind-boggling
so yeah
uh abi manu
i got highest marks in logic but
but hot bad marks in epistemology how to
study epistemology
i don't know there's no one way to study
epistemology i mean
you can get yourself a textbook i
suppose you can
you know
read papers in it you can
put yourself together a curriculum and
you know start with maybe some of the
pre-socratics and move all the way
forward there's no there's no way to
study
any of these these things
and you know who knows what your
instructors are looking for it's not as
if there's a consensus about
what testing looks like
um
all right
matthew have you engaged with the work
of peter slaughter dick uh i am not so
that's kind of a non-starter there
um
forget about me can you explain what's
aristotle's take on time
um
no probably not i mean i'd have to go
back and in order to do a decent job on
that i'd have to review some stuff i
mean he's got that famous phrase time is
the
the uh number of motion so it's
quantitative right
and
we're moving in time you could say or
time is passing
um but i'd i'd really in order to like
say more than those generalizations i'd
have to go back to the physics and spend
some time there um
siddharth what do you think of the
hospital case by thompson regarding the
trolley problem
what do you mean what do i think about
it uh
do i think that
it's a good case do i think that
uh
somebody should do something in the case
i mean people all these what do you
think about questions that people seem
to be asking in this one we gotta we
gotta like get a little bit more down to
proverbial brass tacks
chris i saw you mentioned philip k dicks
we can remember
for you wholesale
do you have any general philosophical
takeaways from it i do not
um
it's not a philosophical treatise
and i don't know that dick is trying to
teach us or argue about philosophy
in it it's it's a cool story right and
um
there's interesting ideas that are being
brought up but i don't have
philosophical takeaways i would say
um
alfonso can you recommend
bibliogra a bibliograph some
bibliography around modern practical
reason to overcome the instrumental
reason for modern stoicism logic
actualization i i don't even know what
you're you're asking about there
so no i i don't have a bibliography i'm
not a bibliographer
a bibliography is is a
well worked out well-researched document
so no
um
is from aid hope you're doing well any
thoughts on the classic trivia model of
education and or general thoughts and
how you think education should be
yeah i think most of the people doing
the trivium are people you should run
away from because they
are enamored of
a long outmoded
articulation of what education looks
like
and they may be reacting against some
bad tendencies within modern education
but when you listen to them talk they
usually get modern education
pretty wrong and
they'll they'll like bash you know dewey
and they haven't read dewey you know
and i would say
in our time a lot of the people who talk
about classical education are
they're hacks they're full of [ __ ] that
you know they they may like praise
aristotle and they may read a little bit
of aristotle but they usually don't
understand aristotle
the
i'll put it to you this way the people
who were teaching in the
trivium
which involves literature
or grammar right both
the way that you would actually learn
grammar in in the medieval trivium was
by
not just like doing grammar stuff but
actually reading great literature
and using that as examples and then
rhetoric and then logic or dialectic
right i think the people who were
teaching in that would call a lot of the
people who are doing it today block
heads and kick them out of their
institutions so i'm not i'm not enamored
of it and i say this from personal
experience with a lot of people who are
into that now these are generalizations
are there some people who are in good
faith and who are actually quite
competent when it comes to these matters
sure
but they're not the majority as far as i
can tell
um
do i have any general thoughts on how
education ought to be
probably not um
you know
i don't i don't do philosophy of
education
that much except in an incidental way
and i would have to think quite a bit
about i mean i don't think there's a
one-size-fits-all
approach to education i think that it's
good to have multiple models out there
but they should be in communication with
each other and there should be some
accountability too
right
um
noah van hooser is zen of philosophy
um well to begin with zen or chan in
chinese where it originated
is a important school among many many
other schools of mahayana buddhist
whatever you want to call it religion
philosophy way of life um i think a lot
of people who talk about zen
here in the west don't have a clue about
what they're talking about they've read
some you know
uh alan watts or you know some thomas
merton or somebody else who like you
know had some engagement with it and
then they think that like sitting around
and
and drinking tea and
spouting nonsense is zen when actually
it's a very rigorous way to live you
know go to his ed monastery they're
going to put you through your paces and
you're going to read a lot of sutras and
all of that sort of stuff
by the way
zen
you know
or tron
in its contemporary forms and for a long
time in in you know like chinese forms
and um elsewhere
uh isn't just a particular school it
also takes on things from other schools
even like pure land
so
is it a philosophy better to think of it
as
a
set of different
philosophies capable of different kinds
of interpretation
um and uh something that
you really got to put a lot of time into
time and work and study in order to
talk about competently i think
uh paul heinrich i just can't understand
why aristotle's books on ethics are
supposed to be important to me
uh much of what he says is either common
sense or completely arbitrary am i mad
no just um you know at a place where i
was when i was an undergraduate before i
came to realize that the problem was not
with aristotle but with me
and that i was not a careful reader and
that i
wasn't really getting what he was saying
adequately
so you know stick with it maybe you'll
discover um
stuff that you've missed out on i would
say
and you could say the same thing by the
way about many other philosophers you
know
people mentioned leibniz earlier there's
there's quite a few people out there who
disparage leibniz and say um oh he's not
that important he's not that interesting
you know when i hear that sort of thing
i'm like well i mean
i realized that uh he is and uh
it's too bad that you're missing out on
on that sort of thing
um
russell what do you think of spinoza i
think spinoza is an interesting
philosopher i don't buy most of what he
has to say um
and i think
i will i will say this i think there's a
lot of people who you know
are into spinoza but they don't really
understand spinoza well
and
he's what we could call a philosopher
with an aura just like hegel a lot of
people are like oh my gosh hegel he's so
brilliant the phenomenology you have to
read this and you talk to them and
you're like okay so what did you read oh
the master slave dialectic and you're
like
oh okay that's it so so this
little tiny
sliver
of the book
that's what you
you're saying is so genius so brilliant
this this little tiny bit
i think there's a lot of people who do
that with spinoza i think there's people
who do that with nick land and i'm going
to do some writing about this eventually
um
spinoza is not somebody you'd hear a
worship spinoza's a philosopher who's
worth reading and studying and figuring
out whether you
buy into his rather implausible
pantheistic you know mechanistic
doctrine or whether you don't
that's that's what i would say
zach elias do you have any thoughts on
getting an m.a in philosophy i mean it's
certainly something you can do
i don't have thoughts on it as such
mr argentino what was coronavirus why
are you asking me i mean there's all
sorts of
people out there i mean do you think
that coronavirus
is gone
uh people are still getting sick and
dying of it right now
so
um
noah van hooser's seller's attack on
foundationalism successful i don't know
ask the me from graduate school you know
back in the late 90s when i actually
knew what he had to say about it because
people i i knew were into it so
i i have no clue
uh zugie asks are you familiar with
nasim talib's books unfortunately yes i
think he's kind of a
a guru type
and
i'm pretty unimpressed with him
as i am with most of these contemporary
gurus uh zeitgeist oh he's talking to
somebody else um let's see
alfonso what's the modern stoicisms take
there is no modern stoicisms take so
let's stop right there right modern
stoicism is a vast movement that
comprises a whole bunch of people a
whole bunch of
approaches and stuff like that what is
the take on the global collapse
environmental climate energetic atomic i
don't know that there's an atomic
collapse happening
so let's just stick with environmental
and climate which are both connected
together
um
do you think it's linked to antarctica
primitivism no it's not linked to
antarctica primitivism because uh modern
modern stoics are not for the most part
anarcho primitivists um they think we
live in a society and that we have to
like take the society that we live in
and you know make sense out of it um
there's some people that are doing some
writing on this you know christopher
gill uh for example kai whiting
um i mean it's it's clear that we should
care about the environment and that it's
it's foolish to pretend like nothing is
happening i mean here in wisconsin we
hardly get any
uh real snow anymore
and you can tell that the environment
the climate is changing
considerably this by the way is going to
be one of the good places to move to as
sea levels rise and it gets hotter here
in the united states so we're going to
have to figure out what to do with all
those immigrants from the red states
where people don't believe in that sort
of thing but are going to be clamoring
to to live here and that that involves
matters of justice right so we could we
could think about those sorts of matters
but is there like a standard modern
stoic take there isn't um
uh el kettering you've mentioned you see
daria as a second-rate philosopher which
you say isn't a bad thing which of his
views do you find persuasive or
interesting what keeps him from first
rate
um
i mean i like dario's early rigorous
stuff i don't like his silly [ __ ]
middle period and
i'm not that convinced about his you
know later stuff with turned back to
religion and politics so
you know the
properly interpreted there's nothing
outside of the text brilliant insight
right
um i don't know that i said that dario
was second right i think you're probably
blurring that with with somebody else
but i think that a lot of peridot's
middle period stuff when he was a star
is kind of kind of garbage uh i think
that his later stuff is interesting but
it would have benefited
from being edited darida you know the
same thing happened to him as happens to
so many other people it starts out doing
really interesting
well-informed rigorous
work
that you can look at and be like oh yeah
that's that's good stuff you know wow
there's some real insights there
this guy knows a lot of [ __ ] right and
then he becomes a big deal and then
because of that he starts believing the
hype that everybody's saying about him
and then he just starts churning out
self-indulgent kind of [ __ ] you know
um which occasionally has a good good
piece in it here and there right but
that's you know
that's that's the
big problem
um
reuben says do you still find it weird
after all these years as a philosophy
professor that the majority never asked
themselves the deep what and why let
alone doing it consistently
i never found it weird
i didn't find it weird as an
undergraduate i didn't find it weird as
a graduate student and i didn't find it
weird as a professor
and i kind of look at it as if you're
you know
um i mean
if you're reading historical philosophy
isn't that what plato says
wasn't that what what aristotle says why
would it be weird you know why would we
assume that people would just naturally
gravitate to this difficult
complicated doesn't have easy answers or
if they do usually the easy answers are
the wrong ones
why would we assume that that is um
you know the uh
the um
the default for human beings when it's
never been the default for human beings
that they sort of like get philosophy or
get interested in it
so
all right uh
let's see here
just a little bit
um
russell henry bieber what are the books
every philosopher should read i don't
think there is a
uh list of books that every philosopher
should read
i mean you can bet that it's probably a
good idea to read plato right do you
have to read all of his dialogues i
don't think so i mean we started out
early on talking about the euthodemus
you know it's worth reading is it worth
reading as much as reading the symposium
i would stick with the symposium or even
the protagoras you know or the gorgeous
um
but yeah i don't i don't try to come up
with these
reading lists that everybody should
should have to have
um
bicameral monk do you have any thoughts
on psychological egoism do you think
it's circular trivially true i don't
even think it's true because
psychological egoism says that
everything that everybody does is done
you know out of self-interest at bottom
and i i don't think that's actually the
case
um
i think the justifications of it are are
usually rather circular
um and i think that you know you always
gonna ask why why would somebody be so
invested in claiming that you know
um that's kind of a funny thing
to
think about all right so we got about 10
minutes left i'm gonna kind of skip
around a bit and i'm not going to uh try
to read everything
because no way we're going to get to it
all so let's let's pick out some
some fun questions here's a good one
from kahan sudev did hegel really come
up with thesis antithesis and synthesis
he did not as a matter of fact you're
rarely going to find anything like that
in his work he he does like triatic
structures but that's not thesis
antithesis synthesis
ficta who
predates hagel
uses that but you know not not as
consistently and it's kind of you know
garbage hegelians
and um
popularizers to stay with this thesis
antithesis synthesis thing i i will say
that marx um contributed to that as well
um
[Music]
popularizers of philosophy like william
durant who's you know the story of
philosophy is is a bestseller you can
find in bookstores all over the place is
a
careless writer who
certainly is
contributing to that cobleston by the
way uh
in his history of philosophy discusses
this and says yeah
not really therian hegel so not all
historians get that get that wrong
um let's see what else we got
nako is pro racist something that we
really control
is the if the the assumptions we control
it absolute according to the stoics true
if no what really influences it
you've got a category mistake here
project is not
something we really control or really
don't control it is us controlling it
so
you know it's sort of like when people
are like
so
um
[Music]
god is the first cause the cause of
everything what caused god and you're
like did you not hear first cause
so the question you're asking already
shows you're getting something kind of
mixed up there
um obviously lots of things flow into
proirasis and and influence it
um but you know
both for for aristotle by the way who is
the first person to use prioris this is
a technical term
and for the stoics and for other people
who use similar terms like voluntas or
will
um
[Music]
yeah we control it it is how we control
things it is something that controls
itself so
so yeah
let's see
um
christine joy garcia what are your
thoughts on stoic pragmatists i think
that that's kind of a
mishmash of stuff
i've got lox stoic pragmatism which i
have to review
i know that the historical pragmatists
messed up in their interpretations of
stoicism
and i think you could just do stoicism
without having to like
make it into something else
you know if you want to be a pragmatist
go be a pragmatist if you want to be an
existentialist go be an existentialist
you know uh being a stoic isn't
something that you like sprinkle a
little bit on you know like putting some
mozzarella on your pizza or to put some
parmesan on your pizza it's already got
mozzarella right uh and then call it oh
it's a parmesan pizza no you gotta
you know you're taking a little bit of
stuff from something else i don't i
don't really buy the
project
um
let's see here
[Music]
so this is from tristan hero worship and
philosophy or popular philosophy sounds
like a great video idea do you think
hero worship like you described was
significant as it was in the past for
philosophers as it is now you can always
find it um
except you know in in times when
philosophy there isn't much of it going
on i mean
if you're in the
uh
middle ages
you know during the carolijanian
renaissance when it's
you know
mostly monks who are literate and
trying to you know spread this to
society now that a little bit of
peace has been attained under under
charlemagne and there's going to be a
reconstitution of learning a lot of
people are worrying about philosophy at
that time
not a lot of hero worship going on you
kind of need to have a
literate
book reading
public in order to have that sort of
thing going on
uh when you do yeah you find all sorts
of superficial takes where people are
claiming that they're like
into this philosopher they've got the
best solution for everything
and they don't really know what they're
talking about they're
you know kind of fakers uh so i think
that that's common
bottom head what do you make of
republicans asking democrats to define
woman totally in bad faith
i mean we should focus more on how
republicans
actually treat women
and
um
you know the misogyny that you
very casual and ingrained misogyny that
you find even among republican women who
are often like surprised i i can't
believe that they treated me so badly
when i've been like selling out my
fellow women you know
um similar things going on as well
um
let's see
a lot of back and forth about that
um
somebody has a funny thing cheese rafts
from wisconsin to rescue the rest of the
us in the coming floods
i mean we're not going to have coming
floods it's just that sea ride sea
levels are going to rise and that is
going to like turn a lot of louisiana
into
swamp again
and coastal cities are going to have a
lot of problems
and
you know places where it's hot and
they're super dependent on air
conditioning and all the power supply
that goes into that
are going to become even more so
a lot of arable farmland will become
unarable and other places will become
you know
places where you can grow things
a donkey asking for a friend who's kind
of modern man is ahead or diogenes who
wants to shift to something a little
more accessible
to the normie fans out there any
suggestions on rebranding
um
i don't even know what that's
quite asking
diogenes could be diogenes and even
diogenes was kind of a prick
so people who fancy themselves diogenes
are usually
like cheap knockoff pricks and it's not
a very good way to live you know they
see similar stuff with people who
idolize um charles bukowski
and you know
try to live like him and you're like
that's not really going to work out for
you and i don't want to hang out with
you anymore
how do you rebrand um
kind of get your proverbial crap
together right decide what actually
matters in your life
and prioritize that if that involves
like restoring relationships i mean you
know getting into a 12-step program
and doing some of the stuff that they do
could be very helpful like taking a you
know ruthless moral inventory i mean you
don't have to be an addict to think that
that's super valuable to do
going around to the people who you've
you've longed and if you've your
diogenes
um even as diogenes himself you've
probably wronged quite a few people you
might have been speaking truth to power
you know holding the mirror up to
society but you probably acted like a
prick to quite a few people who didn't
deserve it so
you know fixing that might be the way to
do it i guess um
well this is nice from philamino thank
you so much for your channel i'm fast
approaching my 17 17 70th year
at 52 you still have plenty of time your
channel has made my retirement more
productive than it otherwise would be
that's very nice to read i'm glad i'm
glad that the videos have been
useful and helpful and hopefully
enjoyable
for you and yeah some of us get like
super lucky you know alistair mcintyre
is still out there kicking at i think 94
years old
and
apparently still has all of his marbles
so to speak
obviously he doesn't have the body of of
a 20 year old or even a 50 year old
but
he seems to be doing okay
anthony long another great example
julianas who i mentioned i don't know
how old she is but she's she's a
certainly emeritus age and still doing
good work
um yeah i mean there's a lot of hope for
us i mean a lot of it winds up being
luck
and genetics and things like that and
you know it seems like my birth families
um
lived pretty long i kind of wish that i
had the my mom's family lembry's jeans
because
a lot of my
grandfather's generation lived well into
their 90s but i'm not genetically
related to so so we get what we get
right unfortunately
oh here's a good question d.c reverend
how would you suggest
using close readings with students who
have zero experience that's a great
question to go out on
so you've got to be able to
suggest to them
what a close reading
should
look like and what it
should provide them with and maybe
finding a few short
examples
of close readings that other people are
doing would be helpful and i like to
describe close readings as we're not
just sticking close to the text
when we run into
problems or questions or
you know things that don't make sense
one of the things we do is we use the
text itself
as a resource rather than just going
immediately to an encyclopedia or
secondary literature we say all right so
plato's um confusing me here
is there anything else in plato's texts
that or even just just this text that
helps me
understand
what's going on and odds are there often
is right and so that that can be a very
helpful component
um
you could also suggest to them too
the goal of a close reading is not to
actually like explain the entire text
it's usually to focus in on
some aspect that you find
particularly interesting or compelling
or worthwhile
that you want to
bring to light and say
there's something here that i care about
maybe that's a good part of it right
affective
maybe the care could be like what the
hell is this crap i can't figure out
what this guy is saying right
but it could also be this is a really
interesting idea and i don't i don't
fully understand it but i want to make
sense of it as best as i can
within the scope of this text so that
those might be ways to get like total
beginners to understand
what's going on in a close reading and
that is a really great question
something i should probably
think about for my own students because
i'm teaching a couple classes where
close reading is
something i want the students to be
doing i'm incidentally i'm going to be
teaching
four classes this coming semester i got
asked
very last minute not even a week ago by
marquette university to take on three
classes
for them um two of which are a new upper
level core class and i'm still kind of
figuring out what i'm going to do with
that
uh it's sort of a problem-based learning
thing and then the other one is a
foundations and philosophy which is you
know intro to philosophy with some extra
bells and whistles and for milwaukee
institute of art design i'm teaching
philosophies of human nature
and so you know i'll probably have my
students do close readings in the intro
and the
philosophies of human nature so maybe
maybe i should
you know this is a good occasion maybe
put together a video about that so
all right uh
don says close reading beer goggles for
the win
uh now beer goggles means something a
little bit different usually it's like
hooking up with somebody at beer or not
at beer time at bar time because you
drank so much beer or shots or whatever
that uh you're willing to sleep with
somebody that you would normally find
below your standards um
can we make a good metaphor
of that to something of a close reading
i don't have to think about that nothing
suggests itself uh right off the
the bat
so all right so this is a good place to
end um i didn't get to everybody's
questions but uh
you know um got to as many of them as i
could
and hope all of you have a great time
i'm gonna
head off get something to eat and then
i've got my philosophy chat for patreon
supporters coming up and then i got to
get to
the
tons and tons of work uh awaiting me
some of which are the product to go back
to one of the questions
of procrastination of having put things
off that i shouldn't have put off and
now now i got to pay the price so all
right i'll see all of you and i hope you
have a great rest of the weekend
you